[拍手]
こんにちは
秦と申します見てわかる方もいるかもいる
かもしれませんけれどもものづくりをして
いる人間です
喋るより作る方が本来得意なのですけれど
も今日こういったしゃべる機会を頂いたの
でまあ皆さんにちょっとでもこの日本に
こういった思いでものづくりをしている
人間がいるまたこれから皆さんが生きる上
で新しい価値の創造できることに僕の体験
が
繋がればいいなと思いますよろしくお願い
します
僕はですね広島県呉市川尻町というところ
で
川尻筆という筆を作っています日本各地に
筆の産地はあるんですけれどもその一つ
ですそこでですね書道筆や化粧筆でそれ
から赤ちゃんの髪の毛を使った体毛筆を
作っています
画像の下2つが化粧筆ですそれからその上
は書道府で赤ちゃんの歌は今回のせないん
ですけれどもおそらく皆さんの中にも作っ
た方がおられるかと思いますこういった筆
はですね
昔ながらの道具を使って手作業で作られて
います今日ちょっと一つ小道具を持ってき
たんですけれどもこれですねこれ串ですね
これクシなんですけどただの櫛じゃあり
ません先々代が作ってもらって先代が使っ
て僕の台にも使ってる代々受け継がれる
クズですこういった古い道具も使いながら
古来の製法を守り続けて今の姿に残ってい
ますなぜそのままの姿を保っているかと
いうと機械化が難しいからなんです動物の
毛1本1本全て違います皆さんの髪の毛
髪質体から入る毛全部一歩一歩違うと思い
ますそれは選別して使い手に合わせた筆を
作る技術はまだ機械ではできませんなので
僕たち職人がこの手で
筆という命を吹き込んでいます
こういった
伝統ある仕事に就くきっかけ少し単純かも
しれませんけれどもお家が職人の家系でし
た
父母祖父祖母が筆を作る姿を見て育ちまし
たそして自分も流れるようにその
業界に入ります写真ではちょっとビーチ
ボール職人のような家には見えてしまうか
もしれないんですけれどもちゃんと
筆を作っているところですそしていざ自分
が工房に立ち
父の横に
肩を並べさせて筆を作る立場になります
どこでもそうだと思うんですけれどもやっ
てみるのと見ていたのと全く違います
とても難しかったです自分の周りに
ちっちゃい頃溢れていて遊んで
触ってたものがすごい苦労すごい点は
すごい工程を踏んでできているものがある
んだなと知りましたとても価値があるもの
があるんだとやってみてより理解できまし
た
そこで一つ思いましたうちの
信念
妥協していてはいいものができないんです
そういった品質のものを作っていますそれ
である数式が生まれました
原料から
妥協を引いてやるそうするとですね
研ぎ澄まされた産物が残るんですそれが
作ることにつながるのだなと思いました
今回このお話しさせていただく機会を
いただいた時に
筆づくりのお話をまずさせていただいたん
ですけどもその時にテレックスのスタッフ
の方が教えてくれました
筆作りって
引き算の美学なんですねと僕は作るのに
いっぱいいっぱいで手をかけること
ばっかり思ってたんですけどもやっぱり外
からの意見って斬新ですねあそうなんだっ
て原料からだけを引いたらいいもんができ
るっていう数式に成り立つんだといいなと
思って今日使わせてもらいました
ありがとうございます
しかしスタート作っていくだけでは
やっぱりダメなんですねただ作ればいいの
かそんな感じのもんじゃないですね
やっぱり作る限りはより上よりいいもんを
目指していきたいんですそのためにはです
ねやっぱりこのいい原料いい原料を生かす
技術それらが必要なんです
幸いうちには熟成された現場があります
50年以上前から寝かせている現状です
そこに伝統的技法を加えてありますそう
することによっていいものができて
品質が守られて使い手を守られて
おこがましいかもしれませんでも使い手を
守ることが一番だと思います
守られることにつながるんだと思いました
そうして出来上がった筆がこちらです
ちょっと遠くの方すみません
これも50年以上前の動物の毛を使って
できたものです
ヤギの毛です当時の食肉の副産物の毛です
それでもそれに手をしっかりかけてやれば
すごくいいものができるんですそういった
ものを作っています
しかしまあ作って守るだけではやっぱり
使ってもらえないですやっぱりそれ知って
もらわないといけない認知してもらわない
といけないPRってすごい僕は作り手なの
で難しいですそれをより実感した機会が
ありますそれがですねこのフランスでの
筆を広める活動です
あるご縁があってフランスに筆を広める
活動に行ったのですがそこで僕は思い知り
ましたもう本当にフランスのイメージと
いうと
芸術であったりとか料理であったりとか
エッフェルと
凱旋門様々なものがありますいい面ばかり
が目につくようですけども
動物愛護の先進国なんですね僕たち筆の
業界のものからしてみれば真逆の存在と
言っても過言ではありません
そういった思いを胸に抱きながらフランス
に行きましたそして次の日のイベントの
準備をしていましたそしたらまだ準備も
そこそこにある方が話しかけてきました私
は動物愛護の活動していますさらに猫
ちゃんを飼っていてとっても大事にして
いるだからあなたの動物を使った毛を作る
そういった文化全く理解できないと今皆
さんにお伝えするからオブラートの言葉で
包んでますけれどもっとダイレクトに
厳しい言葉で言われました僕は日本で
あまりそういった経験がなかったので呆気
に取られてとても驚いたんですけれどもで
もちょっと考えてみるとこの方素晴らしい
なと思いました
なぜならそのことを
ネットでインスタでもTwitterでも
何でもいいでしょう悪口一つ書いてしまえ
ばそれで済んだ話なんですでもその方は
対面で僕に直接投げかけてくれたそして
あなたどういう思いで作ってると聞いて
くれましたなので僕はもうありのままの
ことを伝えましたさはこれも触ってもらい
ましたこの池はですね50年前の食肉の副
産物の毛を使ってるんですよ新たに命を
殺すことはしていませんよ
そしてこの作った筆良い原料をいい技術で
作った筆ですね何年何十年って持つんです
そしてこの
筆を使って書いた作品は何十年何百年って
持つんですよそしてその作品は様々な方に
感動や喜びを伝えるんですよそれに動物=
悪だとイメージを勝手につけないで
くださいと一つだけ分かってくださいと
あなたの
猫ちゃんでも
筆は作れるんです長生きをちょっと切って
いただいて僕に託してくれると小さな筆が
できますそしたらその
筆でと猫ちゃんとそのことを3つで楽しむ
ことができるんですその全て楽しめますよ
その猫ちゃんがもし天井を全うしてあなた
のもとを去った時はその筆がその姿のまま
残りますずっとあなたのもとに寄り添って
くれてますその子をより思い馳せる機会が
増えると思いますそういったものも作っ
てるんですだからどうかこの日本の文化筆
すべてがそうというわけではありません
けどうちの信念はそうなんです
そう伝えるとですねその方の顔は
徐々に徐々にほころんでいってちょっと
笑顔が見えてきました通訳経由での会話
でしたのでダイレクトにすぐ反応は見れ
なかったんですけれども
徐々に徐々に
伝わっていってその方は大変喜んでもらい
ました知らなかった
そういったものあるんだと私は
筆を作るために新たに命を殺して毛を取っ
て
筆を作っているのだと思ったと言われまし
た
ぜひうちの猫ちゃんで筆を作ってほしいと
言われましたそれまで動物イコールダメ
動物を使ったものがダメと言ってた方が
真逆ですよ正反対作ってくださいと言って
くださいました
もう喜んでお受けしましたこれで僕が本当
にいい経験させてもらったなと思ったん
ですけどそこから学んだこと真逆の存在だ
なと思っていた方そこにあったそのコンテ
にあった
疑問なり
偏見なり思ってたことと違うっていうこと
は多々あると思います思いなさいいっぱい
ありますそこにですね
熱になり伝統なり
品質を見せてあげると一番の理解者になる
んだなと思いました本当にこれは紡がれて
きた
熱意だけじゃなく
伝統
品質があったからだと思いました
この業界船業界古い業界です様々な方がい
ます
この同じ作り手であっても
うちであったり他社さんに会ったりその方
にこの誹謗中傷だったりもしないことを
広める方がたくさんいます同じ作り手で
同じ方を向いてると思いきや麻薬の存在の
方がたくさんいりますでもですねそこに僕
が引き算の
儒学を当てはめたいと思いますその方の
発してる少し
嫌な言葉そこから不安や妬み
嫉妬をどけてやるとですねこの業界の新た
な問題点が洗い出されると思うんです
そしてそれを共に解決する一番の理解者に
いつかなれると思いますそういった
ありがたい経験をさせてもらいました
しかしまあそういった経験からですね数年
経ちまして社会が一変しましたコロナです
行き来ができなくなりました直接的に触れ
て
文化を広めるっていう行動ができなくなり
ました
でも
文化を広める
活動ができましたそれはなぜかというと
ですね
現地の方以前の活動で分かってくれた理解
者の方々がいたからですその方々が協力者
となってうちの文化を広める活動を手伝っ
てくれましたリモートという形で全ての僕
の目が行き届いたわけではないんです
けれども前回
参加して分かってくださった方々が僕の
足りないところを補ってくれました話が
通らない聞こえない方には自分たちが教え
てあげてこういった筆なんだよこういった
思いで作ってるんだよこういったインフレ
があるんだよってことを広めてくれました
妹をつないだ先には以前動物愛護の活動で
話させていただいた方が手を振ってくれて
ましたすごく嬉しかったです仲間になった
んだな協力してくれるんだなと思いました
それからフランスのアーティストの方が
うちの筆を使って実演書いてくれました
そうするとやっぱりこんなにいいもんが
できるんだなってことがより伝わりました
ここから僕が学んだことですね相手のこと
を理解して自分もしてもらいますそこに
さらに体験が加わるものならさらなる理解
を得られるんですそしたらもう
協力者になってくれました
そして伝えることが願い叶いました今日の
活動も
伝える上での
協力者たくさんいます僕は先ほど申した
通り喋るのが下手ですなどでその思いを
どうしても伝えることは得意ではないん
ですけれどもその思いどういった思いが
ありますかっていうのをあちらで控えて
いる方々が
文字に起こしてくれて一緒にプレゼンを
作ってくれて様々な補助してくれました
そして今僕がこうスライドを見せながら
話すことが願いかなっています
伝えるということはそういった方々の本当
に
協力の上で成り立ってるんだなということ
がありました
ただ僕もあくまで作り手ですのであまり
こう
伝えるということをしすぎるとですねあの
作る方に手が回らないので今工房では家族
のものがはいを作れよで注文待ってるぞと
いうかなり
切羽詰まってると思うんですけれども今日
はせっかくなのでもうちょっと話させて
ください
それから今話させていただいた作る守る
伝えるこの3つこれだけで終わりたいわけ
じゃないんです
何したいかというと繋ぎたいんですこの
三位一体を生かしてつなぎたいんですそれ
が横でも立ててもいいでも僕は今一番
つなぎたいと思うのは次世代の方に繋ぎ
たいと思います
様々な歴史がありますこの筆にはただ
歴史がある方と美化したいわけじゃないん
ですよ
時代の中で淘汰されていた筆もあります
適応して進化していった筆があります
それだけじゃないですただそのままの形を
残してるものもあるんですだからそういっ
たいいものってつなぎたいんですよ
それにこの業界いろんな方が携わってます
時代に適応しながら原料を調達してくる方
この持ち手ですね軸と言います最高の畜生
学院が筆に合わせて
筆を作ってくる軸を作ってくれるんです
それから
病に伏せて
病に伏せられてですねもう自分が筆ができ
なくなった方その方があんたなら原料を
生かしてくれるAも作るんじゃないあんた
若いもんが作らなきゃダメで言うて
原料を僕に託してくれるんです
それからさらにそうやって作った筆はです
ねこの使い手の方に広がります手に取った
方全てに答えがあって思いがあって価値が
出てきますそうしたものを作れる喜びそれ
があるからにはつなぎたいんです絶やさせ
たくないん
ですその思いはやっぱり強くあ
るっていうのは僕もそのたくさんの方が
つないできたバトの一つを託されたからな
んですよね
父からでもあり他の方でもあり様々な方が
繋いでもらえました
山地を超えて僕に筆づくりを教えてくれた
師匠方もいますそれってすごい
稀有なことなんです
産地が違うと敵同士と思う方もたくさん
いるんです
そうなんですけどその師匠方はですねいや
もう産地関係ないじゃろもうええもん作る
もんが増える早稲田の技術を生かして
くれる若いもんが出てくるほんなら教え
ないけん言うて教えてくれましたそういっ
たバトンを託されてきたからですだから
こそ繋ぎたいんです
まあちょっとこう
偉そうに聞こえる部分もあったかもしれ
ないですけれどもやっぱりこの僕もまだ
35歳です人生100年時代と言われる中
ではまだまだ若輩者ですインフレを作る
自信はありますでもまだまだ若造ですなの
で今ある目標だったりとか思うところ一時
的なゴールを通過したところでそれは完成
した姿ではないと思うんですこ
れっておそらく多くの方に当てはまると
思うんですよね
だからこそでも見えないから
諦めるそうじゃなくてだからこそ見えた時
その片鱗が見えた時
輪郭でも何でも見えた時もしつかめるもの
ならばその時が来た時のために
妥協をせずつい追い求めていきたいです
追及していきたいんです
なかなかとちょっと聞いていただいて
ありがとうございました最後に一つだけ
ちょっとあの知ってもらいたいことがあり
ますこのものづくりの
イメージですねこのきつい汚い手間が
かかる様々なネガティブが先行していると
思いますそんなことないよと言いたいん
ですけれどもごめんなさいうちの工房では
全てあります全部ありますすごく大変です
手間がかかる
毛がいっぱい散らばってるので汚いと思う
方もいるかもしれませんですけど何です
けどその中にですねちょっと顔を通して
この追求したもの
妥協せずにできたものの中にですね本当に
いいもんができるんですそうするとですね
それまであったマイナスのイメージ
マイナスの手間もう様々な負のネガティブ
なイメージいっぱいあると思いますそれが
全部裏返る瞬間があるんです
最高に気持ちいい瞬間があります
ものづくりって本当に楽しいんですそれを
どうかわかってほしかったですでも
やっぱり大変なのは大変ですでも
ものづくりは最高なんです今日はどうも
こんな僕の話を聞いていただいて
ありがとうございました
[拍手]